Sentence should swing the sword.
I forget what you are the rest of the
world.
We're not just sticking with the
printing.
The mind needs books like a sword needs
a wet stone.
Love comes in at the eyes,
the occasional kindness.
We spend all sorts of trouble down the
road.
Don't think someone says before the
word,
but mainly council desires I've added.
It's to align with the phone.
Purse is only one God and his name is
Mayan.
Doesn't concern himself with the
opinions of a sheep.
When you play the game of thrones,
you're when you're dying and only by
admitting what we are,
can we get what we want?
It's always the innocence was going to
die.
I'll be with a song in my hot water is
honor compared to a woman to love.
Doug is coming for all of us like crap
about it.
They say the goes through life with his
bathroom.
Lines are down.
You can often be blind to the innovators
of your side.
God's wanting us to have to take will be
dyed or anything with a cook is easy to
full power resides when then believe it
resides.
There's no appeal for being a good act.
Does not wash out the bad,
bad,
good amount is what are the say?
He is.
I know more Spanish to be cruel than
weak.
No one can survive in this world without
how.
The more people you love,
the way you treat your oath recklessly
and your people will do the same.
People shouldn't live anywhere.
You need to burn shit to keep warm
jugglers.
Singers required.
Plos influence grows like a weed.
Sometimes.
Severity is the price we pay for
greatness.
It's a rare enough seeing man who lives
up to his reputation.
It doesn't matter what we want.
Once we get it,
we want something else.
You waste time trying to get people to
love you.
You'll end up the most popular man in
town.
We do not choose our destiny.
We must do our duty.
No.
All men should keep their words king's
most of all.
Ready?
Hi,
I'm the king.
Has No true cake.
Does that count?
Trying to work out who deserves what and
before long they spend the rest of your
days,
we ping for each and every person in the
world.
There's nothing worse than a late
blooming philosopher.
Thanks for watching.
Hope you enjoyed it.
Check out my sketch comedy channel Dick.
Soak right here.
Just click on down right here.
I'm going to finish editing this video.